Через майже чотири роки після анексії Криму
російська влада не втомлюється "освоювати" ресурси захопленого півострова.
Ось тільки деякі випадки переділу, які трапились останнім часом.
Кримський завод шампанських вин "Новий свет"
продали російському олігарху Юрію Ковальчуку.
Він входить до близького кола друзів Володимира Путіна
та, як заявляє міністерство фінансів США,
є "особистим касиром" російського президента.
Ковальчук та його банк "Росія" котрий рік перебувають під санкціями США та ЄС.
Прибутковий завод шампанського був у держвласності України.
Не менш відоме кримське підприємство "Масандра" спіткала інша доля.
Воно перейшло під контроль Управління справами президента Росії.
Саме на "Массандрі" два роки тому Путіна та Берлусконі
пригощали колекційним двохсотрічним вином.
Пляшка якого, як заявила ГПУ, коштувала майже сто тисяч доларів.
Одним з перших окупаційна влада націоналізувала
і стратегічне підприємство "Чорноморнафтогаз".
А разом з ним - газосховище, трубопроводи, шельфові кораблі,
бурильні установки та 18 шельфових газових родовищ.
З яких активно - і незаконнно з точки зору міжнародного права -
під охороною російських військових кораблів викачують газ.
Щоб не наразитися на міжнародні санкції, багато компаній згорнули свою роботу в Криму.
Проте не усі.
Так, нещодавно агенція Reuters з'ясувала:
одна з найбільших російських нафтових компаній "Татнефть"
щонайменше до літа 2017-го року
вела бізнес на півострові через дочірню компанію.
Лише за даними офіційного Києва,  загальні збитки України
від анексії Криму сягають трильйона гривень.
Справжня сума може бути значно більшою -
якщо взяти до уваги втрати майна громадян
та понад чотирьох тисяч компаній.